do what athletes do every day every day
they are going to the messy
Edge at that place where they could fall
into a th pieces or unlock something
special but what those athletes do is a
radical risk-taking every day incredibly
vulnerable and with people that are
wanting to take their job their friends
their peers and coaches that determine
if they're going to get playtime or not
and we look at them and think like
they're kind of boring that way but we
don't do that we don't go every day and
get to our emotional Edge we play it
safe we play it small we get busy as
opposed to intentional we lie to oursel
and numb ourself and we stay on the
surface rather than going to the places
that they go which is right at that edge
where they could fall apart or be just
right in the presence of a slipstream of
unlocking something special the next
level of their expression